Trump because he wants to do anything to
damage DeSantis and DeSantis is the one
hitting Disney which deserves to be hit
how Trump actually is now basically
taking this side of Disney he's shifting
his tone on Disney this is a tweet from
Pedro Gonzalez Pedro is a great actual
journalist I had him on the show about a
week ago on the panel show he said a
poll Trump shared last month that showed
him leading DeSantis has flipped the
same firm has now DeSantis ahead of
trump post announcement that explains
Trump's ridiculous truth social post
about Disney today siding with Disney
against DeSantis cost him support so
we'll get to that truth social Post in
just a minute they said one Trump just
out I guess Ron DeSantis is not quite as
popular in Florida as people thought I
assume among other things that they
don't want their social security and
Medicare cut and what he's showing you
here is an interactive polls uh poll
survey Florida Republican primary that
had trumpet 47 and DeSantis at 32. now
the second tweet here uh Floridians
choose Trump this is from the Maga war
room and they're showing 47 Trump and 32
percent DeSantis this is back in April
now you'll see where where uh Pedro was
going with this uh three interactive
polls 2024 Florida primary DeSantis now
this is May 25th to 27th so this is the
last couple days now DeSantis is now at
38 which is plus three Trump is at 38
which is -5 Haley someone else undecided
fine and in a two-way match-up uh
DeSantis is now in the lead 40 Trump 39
undecided 21 look I don't like getting
lost before we get to the the other post
I don't like getting lost in all these
numbers right I say that all the time
but there clearly is a shift you don't
relentlessly all day attack the number
two guy especially when he's a guy you
endorsed especially when he's a guy who
is the governor of the state that you
and all of your family members live in
right also is Trump even campaigning
like he's playing golf relentlessly like
is he even out there who's working for
his campaign like something I'm telling
you something weird is going on here
whether you like it or not there is
something there is a shift and something
weird is going on here but here's the
specific uh truth social posts that
Trump put up uh about Disney he said
Disney has become awoke and disgusting
shadow of its former self with people
actually hating it must go back to what
it once was or the market will do
irreparable damage this all happened
during the governorship of Rob de
sanctimonious instead of complaining now
for publicity reasons only he should
have stopped it long ago would have been
easy to do still is I mean that is such
abject meaningless drivel
[Music]
thank you